foreign
good afternoon
today an indictment was unsealed
charging Donald J Trump with felony
violations of our national security laws
as well as participating in a conspiracy
to obstruct Justice
this indictment was voted by a grand
jury of citizens in the southern
district of Florida
and I invite everyone to read it in full
to understand the scope
and the gravity of the crimes charged
the men and women of the United States
intelligence community and our Armed
Forces dedicate their lives to
protecting our nation and its people
are laws that protect National Defense
information are critical for the Safety
and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced
violations of those laws put our country
at risk
adherence to the rule of law is a
Bedrock principle of the Department of
Justice
and our nation's commitment to the rule
of law sets an example for the world
we have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone
applying those laws collecting facts
that's what determines the outcome of an
investigation
nothing more
and nothing less
the prosecutors in my office are among
the most talented
and experienced in the Department of
Justice
they have investigated this case hewing
to the highest ethical standards and
they will continue to do so as this case
proceeds
it's very important for me to note that
the defendants in this case must be
presumed innocent until proven guilty
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt in a court of
law
to that end my office will seek a speedy
trial in this matter
consistent with the public interest and
the rights of the accused
we very much look forward to presenting
our case to a jury of citizens in the
southern district of Florida
in conclusion I would like to thank the
dedicated public servants of the Federal
Bureau of Investigation with whom my
office is conducting this investigation
and who worked tirelessly every day
upholding the rule of law in our country
I'm deeply proud to stand shoulder to
shoulder with them
thank you very much
why Florida sir why did you decide to
bring the case in Florida